vous autour de la table est-ce que vous
avez déjà été franchement au bout du
rouleau dit la vérité benjamin je crois
que oui j'étais au profond au fond du
trou moi non mais tu comprends donc
dommage un moment pas très bien mais
vous savez que le principe du téléphone
c'est un détail qui s'arrêtent de sonner
c'est pas maintenant je me suis habitué
mais ce n'est qu'à une époque il sonne
plus du tout avant vous à payer plus un
appel il ya puis un déjeuner il ya plus
il ya plus nos relations de travail les
arts et médias que vous pensiez avoir
comme comme ami ou comme quand même
heure quand même eu comme copains et
vous appelle pas c'est très dur c'est
très dur et c'est marrant parce que moi
je voulais parce que c'est un peu comme
un boulet là c'est marrant mais
bizarrement depuis quelques temps c'est
sa personne beaucoup le téléphone donc
alors oui ça c'est pas grand chose mais
baissé 6 maschio de bobigny à l'antenne
tous les soirs mais mais mais c'est
assez étonnant c'est ce qui est plutôt
dense pétille comme je suis un peu naïf
je me suis toujours je pensais que les
gens étaient sincères et sans tomber
dans le panneau de la crise est un
métier des plus épouvantables il ya les
très belles rencontres mais il ya aussi
de grandes désillusions mais c'est
souvent au niveau de l'effectif quand on
est très dure près blindés c'est
beaucoup plus facile quand on est trop
sensible ça fait des gros dégâts et toi
t'as quoi être très bien des points
moi j'ai pas j'ai pas eu de problème
pour l'animation et c'est vrai que ouais
à l'époque j'avais été très émotif ou
alors juste et non j'étais un peu
sanguin massa mais mais ça va ça m'a
joué des tours mais c'est vrai que il
faut pas mais il faut pas mettre une
once d'affect dans ce métier pour pas
être déçu il faut vraiment du 17 janvier
siens mais c'est vrai je les fais les
jeux les vécu plusieurs fois aider des
gens ont dit ah ouais ils vous appellent
tous les jours laissé mon ami c'est mon
copain et du jour au lendemain ça
disparaît mais comme ça et ça c'est ça
c'est terrible pour éponger un cercle
d'amis qui est très très restent en
l'état je peux pas vous mentir si j'ai
moins de cinq copains danse mais
maintenant je vais juste moins de cinq
amis le reste c'est cissé des relations
et les patrons de chaînes sont durs
souvent canal au début un jour il ya un
producteur ben ce que j'embrasse mais
christian cathala il a prise à l autre
comme ça et tu vois la courbe là tu vois
quand ça descend ici c'est quand tu
parle alors d'un visionnaire
[Rires]
cela est
je suis resté proche était là quand ça
n'allait pas du tout et qui est venu
dîner à la maison c est franchement il y
avait alors il n'y avait aucun intérêt à
venir me voir c'est c'est thomas
valentin c'est un amour leur et voilà
mais c'est le seul patron de m6 que
jeannin il le somme assez atypique c'est
un mec exceptionnel et pour bien faire
aucun interallié on vous savez je
resterai toute ma vie dans le groupe
canal donc bien sûr qu' aucun intérêt
mais je vois là c'était
ici et surtout zéro mémoire dans ce
petit 0 mémoire quand vous avez envie de
speed et
[Applaudissements]
le manque de le voilà aucun
reconnaissance même pas la
reconnaissance 0 mes moyens qui venait
tendu la main vous avez aidé et après
c'est moi il monte il vous écrase comme
une merde ça s'est très ça c'est propre
aussi à beaucoup de soin dans la télé je
dis que j'ai dit en préambule c'est pas
au contraire dans ce métier les très
belles rencontres il faut pas mettre
d'affect voilà